hi everyone my name is sai venom and I'm
a developer advocate with IBM today I'm
excited to introduce a three-part video
series on hybrid cloud architectures
hybrid cloud is a concept that's been
around for quite some time but we're
finding that it's becoming increasingly
used to architect and modernize existing
or legacy applications according to
research we found that 75% of non cloud
applications will be moving to the cloud
in the next three years this goes to say
that if you're not already thinking
about your hybrid cloud strategy you may
be falling behind if you want to learn
more about the basics of hybrid cloud
check out my hybrid cloud explained
video where I cover the basic concepts
of all hybrid cloud architectures in
this three-part series I want to dive
deeper and hit on key concepts that make
up a hybrid cloud architecture and to do
that we're going to start with part 1 of
this video series which is going to be
connect connectivity and
interoperability our core concepts of
hybrid cloud architectures you can
imagine that you have existing
applications that may be running on Prem
working with maybe a private cloud
and you can also imagine you'd be taking
advantage of public cloud as well and
you have services that are running
across all of these environments we need
a way to securely connect them to one
another so taking advantage of solutions
open-source solutions that we have
things like Linux based containers
kubernetes is steo as well as multi
cluster management tools message crews
brokers you know the list is endless but
there's a lot of solutions out there
when used properly help you hit that
connectivity that you need with hybrid
cloud architectures in part two we want
to talk about modernization so we'll be
switching gears a little bit here you
can imagine that with existing
applications that you may have you may
have a monolithic application that you
want to break apart and move to a public
cloud and that might allow you to take
better advantage of scaling that public
environments offer that's a very simple
use case and and one of many when it
comes to modernizing your applications
in part two I'm going to hit on
strategies to modernize those legacy
applications which is a core part of
hybrid cloud architectures in part three
we want to talk about security we're
finding that you know every year you're
hearing about a different data breach
and we're hearing about privacy
regulations that are becoming
increasingly more strict being imposed
on companies the fact is moving to hyper
cloud might scare some folks but we have
the right solutions to ensure that you
can take advantage of your existing
on-premise 'its the security and and the
ease of use that you have there while
securely moving some of your assets to a
public or even a private cloud this
allows you to kind of have the comfort
of taking advantage of all the resources
you have on public cloud while still
maintaining the security that's required
of your architectures I believe that
this three-part series is going to help
tackle the three major issues that you
may have when architecting your hybrid
cloud
locations as always we're always
checking for your comments and your
feedback and if you have any other
topics that you'd like us to cover in
light boarding videos please let us know
below be sure to subscribe and stay
tuned for future videos in this series
and if you want to get started on your
hybrid cloud architecture journey right
now go ahead and check out some of the
links that we have below and the videos
that we have lined up thank you